Women: Good evaluation is vital to the success of your application.
Users are likely to download apps that have been rated well.
We've compiled 10 basic tips to further evaluate your app.
Read and understand the creative vision of Android apps
On the Android Android developer site.
By embodying principles in your application,
Attract users,
And make their lives simple,
And wonderful.
Personalize your design.
The superb design results from user understanding,
However, it extends the limits of use.
The multidimensional design is the spirit of design
For a world full of multi-screen devices.
Providing a comprehensive guide
Visual design, and design movements and interactions
Across all form factors and devices.
You can get started on Google / com / design.
The application of smart phones does not necessarily mean
It'll be a great app for your tablet, Wear, or TV.
So do not copy your app to other form factors.
But must be configured according to each usage situation.
Tablet users will want to try your app,
So take advantage of the extra screen space.
A Wear user will want to provide information in a timely manner.
Focus on specific actions that will be useful here and there.
Great, usable and high-value applications are often simple.
See a critical look at menus and action buttons
Focus on what the user wants
And what it really needs to do.
You will be given quality guidelines
Minimum starting point for application testing.
By performing these tests on each form factor
Compatible with your app, you can ensure that your app
Will meet the basic requirements upon which it is based
All great Android apps.
You should test your application on as many real devices as possible.
Google Cloud Test Lab can help you
Test the devices that you can not get.
Subscribe to the Developer Console
To receive test reports for your initial and experimental applications.
These reports help you understand
Upload results of your app
And interact with it on common physical devices
From different geographical areas.
Send the application source to the testers
And key members of the Users Forum
And to those who are keen to provide comments.
Then use the beta test feature
In the Developer Console
To distribute the test application
So that you can start compiling their comments.
Urging users to sign in can cause them to stop using the application.
Let them appreciate what your app offers first.
Ask them to sign in, when that makes sense,
For example, in the case of content conservation and customization
Get jobs across devices and more.
The developer console lets you read user comments
And respond to them.
Comments help you understand the most important issues
That users in your app are experiencing.
Response, acknowledgment, reform.
Inform users that repair will not be an immediate update.
Try to win the loyalty of the followers.
This app ratings will reflect mutual respect.
Monitor causes of breakdowns and downtime
Using the information provided by the developer console.
Keep this information closely
Fix any problems as quickly as possible.
High app ratings and great reviews will deliver good results,
By encouraging others to download and use the app.
For more information, go to the Distribution section
On the Android Android Developer site.
If you want to get more tips on improving
Performance of your app or game and building a better business for apps,
Check out other videos in this series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.